nicole gundlach prepares food for her
children they have been at school all
day and now back at home they're hungry
but if their needs are simple their
mother's task is not because putting
food on the table is becoming
increasingly more expensive with the the
food prices going so high it's either
spending two or three times on the
amount of food or buying the the amount
that i could afford and then we have to
eat less food so mainly it means for me
buying less food and i'm the one who is
going hungry or not eating meals so that
the kids can get enough food rising food
prices have implications for others too
yozita hattanto runs a vegan restaurant
in berlin's penslawa bayak district the
lucky leak has won high acclaim from the
michelin guide with a reputation for
fresh and seasonal fare with a personal
touch but maintaining those high
standards with ever higher prices is
becoming increasingly difficult all my
suppliers increased their prices so when
i
checked my bills i was like what
yeah and of course i had to compensate
it in some
way and yeah the only way was to
increase my um
the prices for the menus these
increasing prices are happening in many
sectors of business and industry across
germany
millions of citizens ask themselves
every day will my money be enough will
there be enough at the end of a month
these are very serious questions
questions which need a clear answer the
government has initiated extensive
relief measures one short-term measure
the german government has a lighted on
is cheaper public transport throughout
the summer months for a flat rate of
nine euros or around nine and a half
dollars each month passengers can use
local and regional buses trains and
trams to travel anywhere inside germany
at eu summits and again at the recent g7
summit inflation has been discussed and
it's clear leaders are trying to say we
feel your pain the last time inflation
was this high was back in the early
1970s when this wall still divided this
city back then a phrase was coined to
describe the combination of stagnant
economy and rising inflation stag
flation
for now ministers say the threat of a
return to that era is distant
for now
dominic kane al jazeera berlin